je m'appelle liée à dominique nadeau et
j'ai besoin je suis une jeune fille
passionnée de tchoyi des et de lecture
j'affectionne surtout les livres dingue
j'aime également les émissions qui porte
sur ce sujet je m'intéresse aux
problèmes sociaux parce que j'aime aider
les gens les troubles alimentaires dont
la boulimie et l'anorexie sûr abordés
dans ma présentation bonjour je
m'appelle la démunis
je suis ici aujourd'hui pour pallier un
important problème à la société la
perfection notre accord j'appréhende va
ressembler aux idéaux comme vedette dans
les revues au mannequin mais si muscu
mais cela n'est pas toujours la réalité
ali problème qui rejoint la perfection
nette record et les troupes amateurs
après avoir visionné une émission j'ai
appris que deux artistes ont été
atteints d'un trouble alimentaire et
cela m'intéressait je vais vous parler
l'anorexie la boulimie y répète sa vie
de 1,3 alimentaire est des autres
complexe caractérisé par une habitude
alimentaire
anoman les troubles mentaux doivent être
pris au sérieux
est ce que ça vous est déjà arrivé de
vous leur semblait quelqu'un dont 906
goulet c'est le cas de vriendt parler
l'anorexie est l'importance de prendre
10 points même souhaite poids est normal
vous peur des autres solutions liées au
contrôle de votre alimentation
voici quelques symptômes physiques et
puisque logique de l'anorexie ou
anormalement bas peau sèche anomalie
cardiaque ce qui faisait quelques
battements du coeur à normal 10000 sont
la masse se sucrer d'une fragilité ouzou
et est hautement tout de lma faible
estime de soi isolement social et
difficultés relationnelles
marilou la cuisine ya autour du 18
provinces par jour a été atteinte
d'anorexie
la boulimie une présence de j
alimentaire ce qui va te prendre une
quantité excessive de nourriture en pet
un an ni un sentiment de perte de
contrôle
voici quelques symptômes physiques et
psychologiques de la wind voit
habituellement normal déséquilibres
électrolytiques
si tu veux un déséquilibre en sels
minéraux et l'autre cas anomalie
cardiaque est rattachée gamer fais pas
ci ne soit on dit goût capabilités
études et relationnel sochi et loire la
fan de justin trideau a été atteinte de
bruit
saviez vous que 30%
on sent après un suivi en thérapie un
autre après quelques rigide et un autre
pont sans risque rallye ce qui faisait
que la maladie va rester pour toujours
de plus 10 % voire de complications
reliées à leurs trouvailles mandat
cela constitue le plus haut taux de
mortalité de tous les troubles de type
psychiatre et au besoin vous pouvez
consulter le site à l'aide et les
personnes qui vous a aidé son regard les
maisons éclairci le sheed à québec
il est médecin j'espère que vous avez su
pourquoi l'être humain mentale doivent
être pris au sérieux
je souhaite que cela passe par la tête
vous allez en parler
répéta comment il faut en parler merci m